with you well Donald Trump has many
critics at home and abroad he's also
been the butt of jokes on shows like
Saturday Night Live and with comedians
and critics including Egyptian satirist
Bassem Youssef and he joins me in studio
to talk more about this blossom thank
you so much for being with us thank you
for having me well one of the reasons
that you're here is the Berlin Film
Festival we're gonna get to that in a
moment but first I do want to ask you
you know you are one of the most famous
comedians in the Middle East you've been
famously called the Jon Stewart of Egypt
and your show there had 30 million
viewers and you now live in the u.s.
what is your take on Donald Trump
because a lot of people have said that
political satire at this point what are
you satirize I mean how do you go about
making fun of or not of what's happening
in the US well Donald Trump is a is a
very easy joke to make he is a joke his
campaign for us is a joke of course he's
a joke for us
but for his supporters he is the best
leader president can be I mean we we
have to admit that we are living in the
bubble I mean when he was like
performing in his the primary debates in
general elections we always said like
there's no way that she's gonna win but
like we didn't see that the the his
supporters liked everything he said his
he had basically based the whole
campaign on demagoguery on we call it
xenophobia call it hate but for his
supporters that was like the best thing
ever I mean right now there's a lot of
reports that are interviewing a support
and said like is the best present ever
and he's doing exactly what he has
promised on the campaign trail he he is
very easy to make fun of and he reminds
us with a lot of what's happening in the
Middle East but we we just have to wake
up and and and and and realize that not
because it is an easy joke to make that
he would be impeached soon or anything
because he still have a lot of support
within his circle of supporters so he
has been very good for comedy
he's for many comedy jokes I have to ask
you were actually at some of trumps
rallies in the summer during the
campaign what was that like
oh it was interesting it was the same
echo-chamber that we find in the Middle
East the people who are just parroting
the same statements of support of stuff
that doesn't really make sense for us
but it really makes perfect sense for
them they they would support stuff that
might be even against their own
interests most of his supporters are
people for middle-class Americans who
basically are voting for someone who is
bringing all of the big rich businessmen
into power he is giving tax breaks to
the top 10% and he could be a real
threat for them losing their health
insurance but it doesn't matter they
like him because they like what he says
even it doesn't make sense for them it
makes perfect sense
he has galvanized people for a common
source of hate is basically it doesn't
be a lot of people lab voted from
because he they hated the other side one
common source of hate has turned out to
be Muslims you're a Muslim living in the
u.s. how does it feel to be a Muslim in
the US well for me personally I mean I'm
living in California so like it's a blue
state where I don't really have any
sense of discrimination but as much as
we are talking about what Donald Trump
rhetoric has done to not just Muslims or
other minorities we should not actually
forget or ignore that we in the Arab
world and the Muslim would have the same
kind of rhetoric I mean to be honest we
are afraid that that Trump will do to
Muslims but many of the majority Muslim
countries to to non-muslims I mean we
there yes there is a hint of racism a
hint of discrimination against Muslims
against other weaker minorities but we
have to admit that we are actually doing
the same thing for others I mean and and
I've said this many times the those
scenes that we've seen in in airports
and in JFK in LAX that those Christians
use secular non-religious people who
went out to support Muslims not because
they love Islam or not because they love
Muslims but they are with
supporting what the what they think are
human values we have not seen many or I
don't think that we will see that
anytime soon in that many of the Muslim
countries supporting people who are not
Muslims to defend their rights and and
this has been the problem in the Arab or
there are people who are in the middle
who are trying to support the minorities
of the of the non-muslim minorities the
rest of the non-muslim minorities and
they are being crushed by the mainstream
religious authorities and there and many
of the military dictatorships because
it's it's been used as a tool by the
military dictatorships so we should also
address the hypocrisy that we have in
the airport and it doesn't it doesn't
mean that we should stop talking about
what Donald Trump is do I think we
actually have a clip of you speaking to
some hoodlums in the US about what they
think of the trump presidency let's
let's take a look at that what's just
like here being a Muslim I'm not a
Muslim not Muslim I'm not a Muslim I'm
not a Muslim no I'm not Muslim if you're
not Muslims what religion are you
Catholic
I'm Syrian Christian Syrian Catholic I'm
Lebanese Catholic and Jewish I'm Sikh
make sense yeah so you're not Muslims I
mean they're only targeting radical
Islamist terrorists right not at all not
at all what why I was asked by the
flight attendant to please get off the
plane
and I asked her why and she wouldn't
tell me why and she'd say we don't have
to tell boss I'm looking at that that
very much speaks to the American concept
of identity and shifting identities
various identities but what is life like
in the u.s. compared to being at home in
Egypt where you had to leave because of
apparently what was called insulting
Islam and insulting to then President
Morsi yeah but I actually left after
that after I've made fun of the people
who came after the Muslim Brotherhood
they didn't leave at the time what was
left after that but it is the clip that
you just show that it shows that like
you don't really have to be a Muslim you
just have to look different you know
those people were not Muslims they were
like
like they were Jewish divorcee but they
were when hate comes when xenophobia
comes it doesn't look at your ID card
it doesn't look at like how religious
you are you could be called Mohammed
then you could not be religious it could
be 80s or it could be
someone who looks like a middle-eastern
but you could be a Jewish it doesn't
matter what actually as a matter of fact
one of the very first victims of 9/11
hate crimes after 9/11 happened one of
the very first victims in New York was
at a Christian Coptic Egyptian because
you look Middle East and you look there
and so when xenophobic um it doesn't
really discriminate it comes it lavishes
against everybody and it is very
dangerous and this is why I'm I'm I'm a
big vocal I'm a bit vocal against this
because it will affect anybody and all
of these people I mean it's sad there's
a lot of Arabs who are supporters of
Trump yes they are like yes so them and
we have seen how that can bite them in
the butt I mean there was like a family
a Syrian family that were denied entry
in the United States they voted for
Trump they are Christian and they were
denied entry into the United States
because they looked they sounded they
their names were me the eastern it's it
is very it's a very dangerous game to
support hate because you think it will
it works well for you because it doesn't
it's an important message to take away
from that of course I do want to ask you
about the reason you're in Berlin and
there's a documentary playing at Berlin
Allah about your life and Burke tickling
giants maybe you could just tell us how
important it is to use comedy to tackle
some of the problems that you've been
tackling well comedy is a non-violent
way to protest to to show your your
support to a certain cause to to cast
your opinion and I think and we were
very happy that we want an award in the
ever cinema for PCF in festival surtex
lee the director has been following me
for four years then a wonderful job and
we're very happy that's finally paying
off and I hope that people will let see
the movie when it comes out
alright bassem youssef
thank you so much for joining us on DW
today